Speaker 1: OK. Let's go next to God. I always
struggle with this. Alisa Medusa from Dallas.
Did I get it right this time? Oh.
Speaker 5:
Honestly, I'm giving you an A-plus for that,
because I could tell that you've been putting
in the practice, and I really do appreciate it.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Do you do most people
just call you? Oh.
Speaker 5:
Oh, yeah, because I mean, they have the
same issue with butchering my name. OK,
so I mean, it's because like my parents
are from Nigeria. Yeah, I was born here, so
you'd have to blame my mom for that.
Speaker 1: Fair. Well, let's we'll do
that on a different episode.
Speaker 5: Yeah, so again,
thank you so much for taking my call. Today, I
wanted to talk about something different. And it's
in regards to food and I mean, I know it's not a
very attractive topic topic to be talking about,
given how we're talking about Ukraine, Trump
and Biden. But I feel like food is a big
issue. They're not a big issue, but like obesity
in general in the United States is obviously
a very concerning issue that not enough people
are talking about. And I feel like, you know,
most of it stems from, you know, our poor guidance
and education on food in general. Like the good
example of this is the first aid pyramid that
came out and like I think the 80s for the United
States, where, you know, the very bottom of the
food pyramid said that we should have six to 11
servings of bread pasta. Right? But like less
servings of vegetables and fruit? Yep. I mean,
I have no idea how that makes sense whatsoever,
but I also know that, you know, unfortunately,
big food, a.k.a. the food lobby, you know, they
were, you know, pressuring, you know, the USDA
a lot in terms of, you know, making sure that they
would be able to like, push their products. So
I know I kind of went all over the place with
this, but I guess my question is, what do you
think that like we could do to, you know, combat
this issue with obesity? And I guess, you know,
yeah, like what do you think that we could do?
Speaker 1: It's such a big topic. I mean, there's
so many issues here and oh man, and it also gets
very touchy politically to talk about obesity.
One of the there's a bunch of different
things here. First of all, of course,
there's an educational aspect to it where a lot
of people have been given bad information or no
information about, you know, what it actually
means to eat like a healthy, balanced diet.
Number two, you look at marketing and the way that
marketing for food products, not for ingredients,
for food products, because that's what they are,
steers people towards unhealthy food. I mean,
most of the food that's marketed is not
healthy because just basic ingredients
don't really need marketing. I mean, OK, like
you'll see like avocados in general advertised
or sometimes like milk generally. But for the
most part, the advertising is for finished food
products. You then see the financial incentive
where, you know, just growing corn. It's like,
OK, it's just corn, and that's what it is. But if
you can separate corn into 10 different products
and then use them as additives and bump up up
above, you can generate more profit. But you're
also giving people extremely processed items
habits that are set by parents for young kids
and the age at which, you know, kids start having
juice and soda and candy and this type of thing.
There's so many different things here that it is
just a massive problem to get our head around, and
there's no there's no easy solution at this point.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I totally understand, and one
book that I've been like, you know, looking into
reading, it's called food politics. I'm not sure
if you're familiar with the book, but I'm probably
going to pick up the book sometime soon to get a
better understanding of that. But yeah, thank
you so much for taking my call and really quick
special shout out to David Pepper. Really good
interview that you did with them. I actually know
him. Not like super personally, but I've met him
on campus at the University of Cincinnati, so I
was like, really shocked to see you like David and
David interviewing each other. So again, thank you
so much for everything that you do. And again,
good interview and I hope to talk to you soon.
Speaker 1: All right, sounds good. Thanks
for the call. Always great to hear from. Oh,
let's talk to Brian from Eastern Shore, Maryland.
Not a place I've heard of before, Brian. Brian,
you're on the air. You've got to unmute in
order to talk to me, though. Now, boy. That's
too bad. Things were going so well, they
really were. I guess, no, no, Brian, there.